all right so welcome everyone
uh we're going to start here in just
actually a couple more minutes i see
that a lot of people are still
joining so just be patient we're going
to
just be starting maybe let's give it
another couple of minutes
uh
okay welcome everyone to this webinar
uh we will talk today about
the genomic analysis of stars cove
2 new variants in
this time when the vaccine is starting
to be administered all over the world
and so what we want to do is we want to
just discuss some of the
variants that are appearing and what are
some of the biological factors behind
this
and uh first of all um let me introduce
our first speaker so dr
kasulist who is the head of department
of pathobiological sciences
and he's also the director of the
division of biotechnology and molecular
medicine
biomed at the school of veterinary
medicine at the louisiana state
university in baton rouge in louisiana
and he is also the principal
investigator of louisiana biomedical
research network lbrn
and the president of the national
association of idea principal
investigators navy
so gus i will pass it over to you
okay thank you elia let me share my
screen
um
okay i hope everybody sees my screen
right now
uh let me know there's an issue yeah we
can see your screen but we don't see the
full slide we see i think
the presenter view oh this
is potentially an issue that we've never
resolved here
um
you see
if i put on the presentation mode that's
where it goes
so i just wonder if there's a trick that
you know
uh yeah down there yeah down there if
you um
i think uh you see you know go back to
that screen real quick
okay in the presenter mode
in the presenter mode and on top
you see you have and show tips and then
swap displays
so click on swap displays it's on the
top left corner
okay swap this place there we go
now we can see the right view you did it
okay all right
that's good to know okay well um
thank you everybody for attending uh
thank you live for
the introduction what we're gonna try to
do today
is give you a glimpse um perhaps
on uh what is going on now for all these
new variants that have been appearing
worldwide
and we hope that this introduction
is uh a sort of an introduction of a
couple different things that we're doing
with
louisiana biomedical research network as
well as with lsu
we have formulated the graduate course
pbs 7003
section 2 that will be starting
somewhere
mid-february concentrating on
analysis tools bioinformatics tools for
looking at sequences from simple
alignments all the way
to structural prediction and looking at
some of the topics that we'll be
discussing today
also in addition uh in collaboration
with find biotech and
librotsky that was our organizer for
this webinar
we're going to be offering a cadre of
different
bioinformatics courses that will be
virtually delivered
through the lbrn network and it will be
underwritten
by a brn for those that belong to the
lbrn
network and we hope that vinebot tech
will also extend the discount
for others that may be relating uh
indirectly to our network one way or the
other
so um i want to do a brief introduction
to the topic uh
some time ago i gave a full hour lecture
on the molecular and cellular biology of
sas cove ii
and coronaviruses specifically and that
lecture has been taped
it was as in fact two hour lecture
because we had
my lecture up front and eli brodsky gave
the second part of the lecture
where we did a very detailed analysis of
the molecular cell biology
of charles cove ii and that lecture is
taped and is available
i believe on the lbrn network for those
that may want to
hear more of the specifics of the
molecular cell biology
and other tools that have been used to
analyze
those genomes and the structures
of the predictive structures of
different proteins so
as an introduction today what i want to
do is focus specifically
and highlight the possibility
in fact the actuality that coronaviruses
are really more error prone that people
think
because there's a lot of
misunderstanding uh discussing the fact
that
the rna depend on our napoleon rates
that's important for the replication of
the virus
has proofreading activity therefore the
genomes
shouldn't really be that variant but in
fact as you'll see and we'll be
discussing
that this coronaviruses exist as a swarm
a
quasi species a complex set of different
types of our strains
that could then be selected based on
immune selection
or antiviral therapy and so on so what
we see
and the take-home message is what we see
now are these emerging variants
is not really a surprise it's just
basically the interaction of the virus
with the host
perhaps even the additional pressure
that we're putting
on this quasi species with these
vaccines
that ultimately uh selected variants
would be
selected replicating at higher level and
we can see either increased
pathogenicity
or hopefully in the long run it
decreased pathogenicity as the virus
evolves and adapts to the host so in
brief then
um i've done that introduction in the
past i just want to remind you
that corona and such viruses are not
particularly new to us right now
we had the severe acute respiratory
syndrome back in 2002
also from uh from uh china originated
belonged to the beta coronavirus group
it was also transmitted from bats to
civets and civics was the intermediate
horse
to humans we had an outbreak uh more
than 8 000 cases
774 deaths and fatality rate of 9.6
percent
so this virus was quite lethal
but it did not spread very well and that
has to do
with the receptors that the virus was
using at the time
she was very quickly contained and we
didn't have major
epidemics epidemics we also have the
cousin virus the middle east respiratory
syndrome virus maris another coronavirus
is 2012
or even in saudi arabia again the same
group of
viruses it was transmitted from camels
to humans more than 2 400 cases
858 deaths and a fatality rate of 34.4
very lethal virus again it goes very
quickly
uh isolated because the transmissions
were also only muscle cameo
in hospital settings and
they were very easily contained because
the virus was not easily transmissible
and now we have the 2019 uh coronavirus
has got two
uh that appeared in china
and it's the seventh coronavirus found
to cause venus in humans
mind you we have four other human
coronaviruses
that are really a seasonal so every year
15 to 20 percent of respiratory
infections are caused by this already
pre-existing coronaviruses
in fact there is a hypothesis that
perhaps exposure to these viruses
may in fact
prevent subsequent at least lethal
infection but that has not been proven
uh yet so i wanted to also tell you
that not only as we will discuss that
the replication machinery of these
viruses create quasi
species and variants that could be
ultimately selected
but the actual pull of those viruses in
bats
and this is the different types of
viruses we've seen from different
vectors
and the coronaviruses have originated
from bats and the cells grow too
the there are over 400 genotypes of
suscov related viruses
in bats right now that have been
catalogued
mainly from china and we don't know what
other type of coral bars exist in paths
elsewhere
so there is not only ability of the
virus to
alter itself during its replication
cycle
but also the fact that there is a
plethora of these types of viruses
different genotypes already
pre-existing giving the possibility
that any of these viruses could emerge
to be a pathogenic viruses
virus in humans we also know a lot about
coronaviruses
from other corner biases that affect
humans
and you can see here a number of
different coronal viruses of the uh
older category of different groups one
two three
alpha beta gamma and ultimately the
delta group and you have the human
coronal virus to 28d
in the alpha group but we have also
transmissible gastrointestinal bios
forcing coronavirus uh the feline
infections peritonitis virus very
little in cats uh and canine chronovirus
and others
and of course under the beta group we
have the mouse hepatitis virus
and myosin hepatitis virus is actually a
coronavirus
that very accurately depicts the
symptoms and disease patterns of uh
human cells co2 virus in mice in fact
there is a very nice
model for uh studying
the immunopath pathobiology of
coronaviruses in the mouse
system and um also and these viruses
have been extensively studied
their tropics most of them are
respiratory but also enteric
they can alter between respiratory and
ateric as we see also for sarsa
cov2 as you're familiar with from all
the news they have had
any publications that have transpired so
far
so against us cove too the new virus
affects humans there's some indications
that may affect certain animals but
not really at the level whether it would
be used for
transmission and then we have
respiratory mostly infection but also
enteric
a multi-organ infection at some point
including neurological tissues and
neurological symptoms are created
because of subsequent
suscope to infection so uh in our lab we
worked
also in bold mind coronaviruses
respiratory coronaviruses
and that's where in a number of papers
in the early 2000s late 90s
we described the quasi species and we
really
discussed the fact that the unique
replication and transcriptional studies
of chronoviruses
may be causing in vivo generation of
viral quasi species
that is these variants that exist and
can be selected upon
different pressure in fact for bovine
coronaviruses the distinct genotypes
that affect the
mostly respiratory are mostly enteric
and most likely the hypothesis for us at
that point was that the acute
respiratory disease syndrome
in cattle was really caused by bovine
respiratory coronovirus
that then was followed by pastel
hemolytic
infection which is a bacterial infection
and this is exactly what we see
now in saskatchewan infections
so if we look very briefly on the life
cycle of the coronaviruses
the virus is an envelope virus it has a
glycoprotein
a major spike like a protein on the
surface this is the one that really
binds the receptors
at different receptors really determines
the horse range of the virus
the virus then it will enter through
endocytosis it will fuse out of the
endosome
and then it will be ready for
replication
the replication of the plus-slant rna so
the rna is
uh an mrna polarity which is actually
capped in polyate at the very end
and it goes through a negative sense uh
anti-genome
in a replicative intermediate and then
from there on you have sub genomic
messages
all those really uh use a negative dna
intermediate
to produce sub genomic mrnas and this is
one of the mechanisms
where mutations are created in fact the
level of variance
at the mrna replicative intermediates is
much higher than what you see
on the viral genome because by the time
they
replicate and embed it into the genome
as proofreading activity
and stability selection to select a
virus that would be
stable in terms of replication
properties
so this is for muscle but that is virus
but
uh out of uh virology textbook
and you can see the fact that uh you
have up to thirty one thousand
uh 526 nucleotides the typically and
i'll discuss later for sales code too
you have approximately 14 to 15
different operating
frames coding for over 27 different
proteins
and that enhanced the protein content is
because of proteolytic cleavage
uh the virus called zone 48 and brought
here
that process different proteins to
create
more active functional subsequences of
proteins and also it uses as i said
earlier
the different types of rnas that phi
prime three prime
coterminal having the poly a tail and
the five prime name
of the uh genome sequence and this is
done through a discontinuous
replication where basically during the
negative intermediate
the polymerase jumps at the end of that
sequence through
regulatory sequences and adds the five
prime sequence
and that specific phenomenon is actually
error-prone
and this is the 2019 uh viral uh
genome for source cop2 again as i said
14 over in the frames
27 different proteins uh another
mechanism to increase the protein
content
is ribosomal shifting slipping
where basically during the polymerase
here you could have a ribosomal shift
and produce different types of proteins
the major spike proteins is the
fusogenic protein that determines close
range
because it has the binding domain for
different types of receptors
but also importantly enough the virus
encodes a number of different
other proteins non-structural proteins
some of them are structural
like the e-protein and then protein and
while these are non-structural
and have important and yet most of
mostly
unknown functions uh regulating innate
immune response and that's
also pretty important because some of
the variants that we see
are not only in receptor binding or
determining constraints
but some of the nucleotide and amino
acid changes uh may be
in some of these proteins that relate to
how the virus controls the innate
immune response and that subsequent
downstream adaptive immune response
so um i think elia would elaborate
further
uh this importance of the spike protein
the spike protein
is the only fusiogenic protein that
determines the viral entry
binding onto receptors in fusion
it we know that the s1 domain
that contains the receptor binding
domain
determines tissue tropism and it's
it's sensitive to different ph
conformations in order for this
fused jenny proteins the type 1 class 1
viral fusion proteins to
exert their membrane fusion ability they
have to really open up
exposing a fusion peptide which then
intercalates in the opposite membrane
creates a pore function where the trimer
assembles uh to create that pore
and that results in fusion of the viral
envelope with cellular membranes
during exocytosis from the endosome or
in certain other viruses during entry at
the plasma membrane
and of course the spike protein is the
major immunogenic
protein the antigen and this is used
extensively in the vaccines that we'll
discuss briefly here
then again what i mentioned as a
mechanism for entry you have the
viral spike protein attaching to a
receptor potential other core receptors
then you have a conformational change
and ultimately exposes the fusion
peptide here in red
uh to the apostrophe and then the
primary is reassembled
in the posed membrane to create the pore
to mediate the membrane fusion
phenomenon that the results in the
bottle capsid free into the cytoplasm of
infected cells
again uh in terms of receptors i
mentioned the fact that we know a lot
about the different receptors
we know that some of these viruses
transmission has castor endovirus
uses the porcine epn molecule
uh the uh different
other molecules that will actually use
that too uh
but it will also have because your
embryonic antigen m1
for muscle but that is virus would be
well characterized as well as the as a
core receptor the
all linked acetyl klux
so these receptors that bind into these
different receptors really as i said
the host range of the virus and
phosphorus cov2
we know now that it uses the angiotensin
2h2 receptor
and in fact it contains additional
elements for
efficient proteolytic cleavage and
exposure of the fusion peptide
that's why this virus is quite efficient
in infection
as well as spread
and we know that from our animal studies
the deletions of the spike protein uh
can change or
amino acids can change virulence and
tissue transportation
one specific example is transmissible
gastroenterol and gastroenteritis virus
which is really an enteric very high
pathogenic enteric disease in piglets
but if you delete 225 amino acids from
the
amino terminus from this s1 amino
terminal portion of spike
you create the porcine coronavirus which
only causes mild respiratory disease
of pigs and some interstitial pneumonia
so we know that the spike protein its
receptor binding ability in its
physiogenic
functions are very important in terms of
this pathogenicity
we also i want to highlight these two
papers that we published back in 2005 in
2007 for such
call one uh with uh chad petit who is
now an associate professor at the
university of alabama in birmingham and
the only thing
i wanted to tell you is that we found
that not only mutations as would you
expect in the uh the extracellular
portion of spike
but also mutations of the carboxy
terminus of the
spike glycoprotein would affect the
physiogenic ability and
binding and functions of the receptors
so it's not necessarily that you have
mutations only
in the binding or perhaps fusion peptide
but they could be distal
and through conformational changes alter
the function of the protein
altering its horse strains and perhaps
its ability to
uh infect efficiently and spread
we recently in collaboration with dr
sidrama joyce
at ulm we published this paper and i
borrowed one figure from that
what we did we took the spike protein of
the cells called one
and which is called cells old
and the spike protein of the susco two
neuron
and we expressed it transiently in uh
african green monkey cells
and then we stain them uh for expression
and we wanted to see
if the different proteins express uh
cause different types of cell to cell
fusion
which is indication of the ability of
the spike protein to really facilitate
more efficient entry as well spread from
cell to cell
through a cell to cell fusion mechanism
as you can see the old one
causes limited fusion on african green
microcells viral cells here
although the new uh saskov2 virus causes
extensive fusion
and this is also a a property of the
virus that is not
frankly paid much attention in the
literature
because this virus not only enters more
efficiently
through a enhanced physiogenic ability
of the spike protein
but also can spread from cell to cell by
fusing
adjacent cells that is then you could
potentially have
a high level neutralizing antibody in
your lung
fluids but in reality the virus can
spread from cell to cell
without necessarily seeing the
extracellular space
so uh i wanted to bring your attention
again to the accessory proteins
uh for uh the saskof2 although they
uh have similarities to such code 1 and
suscroft2
there are also differences and some of
the pathogenic potential of cells co2
may be relating and depending on some of
these proteins that
regulate the immune system and if you
look at the functions that have been
predicted and again
we don't know a lot about all these
proteins
you can see that a number of these
proteins relate
to innate immune responses for instance
3a
is incorporated with virulent particles
and upregulates enough couple beta
al-8 aurantis and so on it has also a
role in apoptosis induction and cycles
are rest
uh 3b we don't know if it's incorporated
with particle by has a type 1
affects type 1 interferon production and
signaling inhibition
again 6 and so on that interferon
production
and a b cell dna synthesis caspase
independent cell death
apoptosis and other anti-apoptotic
functions so
the um if then it's easy to see and
project that some of these proteins
would be very important in how their
virus
deals with the innate immune response
evading the innate immune response and
any other
um defense mechanism including apoptosis
that the cells may have in order to
really be successful as an infectious
pathogen
so i wanted to focus uh on a new
variance and try to make some
extrapolations as a background to what
uh uh
julia brodsky will be talking about and
this is really from the
central disease control pages
practically the button
as we know we have the that's been all
over in the news now the b117
linux which is the very of concern
because
it's been hypothesized that are not
necessarily more
lethal but apparently up to 50 or higher
more transmissible and yet we don't know
exactly what that means
but that's been mostly on some clinical
data
and anecdotal evidence as opposed to
real experiments that
could really be subject to peer review
the variant has a mutation in the
receptor binding domain of the spike at
position 501
and amino acid asparagine has been
replaced with tyrosine
so this shorthand for this mutation is
n51y
that you see in the literature and the
variant also has several other mutations
including
a deletion of two amino acids that occur
spontaneously
and like leads to conformational changes
in the spike protein
and the mutation of proline 68 to
histidine
here the s112 fury included site and
that hearing site is really processing
the s1 s2
cleavage to facilitate exposure
diffusion peptide and increase
eugenicity
there's also a stop codon on our fate
and this function is uh unknown
the variant was estimated to have first
emerged in the uk
since december 20 the several countries
not have reported cases of b117
including the united states and canada
first reported in colorado
and california as well now apparently
in new york the variance associated with
increased transmissibility more
efficient asset rapid transmission
and there's no evidence so far to
suggest that this variant has any impact
on the severity of disease or vaccine
efficacy however it's noted that the
uh now the population has been affected
increasingly are younger populations so
perhaps this increased
transmission has something to do with
this that gets transmitted
more efficiently into a younger uh
patients the second one is the b151
lineage
the uh this particular virus has
multiple mutations
in the spike protein including uh the
this mutations
uh indicated here in red but i like to
be one one seven lineage so it's
detected in
uk this variant does not contain the
deletion at 69.70
that announced earlier this was actually
identified in south africa
in samples back uh beginning october 20
and cases have been detected outside of
south africa the
the variant was also identified in
zambia and currently there's no evidence
suggest that this variant has any impact
on disease severity
there is some evidence to indicate
though that one of the spike protein
mutations the e4084k
may affect neutralization by some
polyclonal and monoclonal antibodies
and that would be the expectation uh
based on the fact that
this horse these viruses have gone
through hosts that
mount their own immune responses not
necessarily
is subject to monoclonal in the body
therapy or any of the vaccines
uh they may have already been selected
as uh
immune escape variants and the last one
i'll mention that
is also mentioned in cdc is the uh
this particular p1 lineage the
mutation that's shown here and this one
is
has 17 unique amino acids and three
deletions
and contains these mutations there's no
evidence that just some of these
mutations
in the p1 variant may affect the
transmissibility
and metagenic profile uh so far but a
recent study reported on
a cluster of these cases in manoa the
largest city in the amazon region
um and in this region it is estimated
approximately 75 percent of the
population
have been infected with subscribe too as
october 2020
and perhaps this high level of
infectivity led
to this variant being selected much
quicker than it would be in other parts
of the
of the world the emergence of this
variant
raises substantial concerns of a
potential increase in transmissibility
or propensity for saskatoon infections
of individuals
because of the plethora of these
mutations and deletions across the
genome
they uh obviously what are the potential
consequences of happiness virus
you could see that in red and i'll go
fairly briefly on that
the ability to spread more quickly in
people we've seen this
there's already evidence that one
mutation that
the 60 60 14 to g glycine mutation
confers increased ability to spread more
quickly than the wild type virus
uh this particular variant propagates
more quickly in human respiratory
pathial cells in cell culture
outcompeting the 614d original
multiviruses
there's also epidemiologic evidence that
the 614 g variant spreads more quickly
than viruses without imitation the other
consequence would be ability to cause
other milder or more severe disease in
people
so far there's no evidence that this
recently identified core viruses
cause more severe disease than the early
ones other than the fact that there is a
strong
indication or suspicion that this virus
is transmitted more efficiently
the ability to evade detection by
specific diagnostic tests is of concern
most commercial polymerase and reaction
tests have multiple targets though
to detect the virus uh as the ones that
we use here for waste water
detection in our laboratory for this
panoramic variation issue
so basically by having multiple sets of
pcr primers
you would avoid the fact that maybe you
you'll be unable to detect a specific
variant and but that needs to be looked
at every time a variant comes in
because it's possible by accident that
the pcr primers that are selected
will target those altered mutations
which case you won't be able to see that
oops decreased susceptibility to
therapeutic agents as monoclonal
antibodies
obviously if you had targets of
monoclonal antibodies like monolithic
body therapy
which president trump was treated with
if there is that area
where the uh the single amino acid
change could really knock out
the monolith body therapy uh fairly uh
easily
an ability to evade natural
vaccine-induced immunity and that's
where basically these
other open-ready frames are very
important and mutations because we
really do not understand
the immunopathogenesis of these viruses
so everybody is concentrating on the
spike protein because the easier target
when reality there are many other things
that we need to know of how this virus
really controls
the immune response and causes
pathogenicity
in terms of vaccines very quickly i
wanted to just give you a
you know 30 000 mile uh view of
vaccinology
we've been working on vaccines for
quantum viruses quite some time
uh successfully in many a number of
instances unsuccessfully
we have live attenuated vaccines or
foreseen
endemic disease virus uh and that's done
by
serial passage of the virus 90 times or
more
in african green monkey cells the
infectious bronchitis virus it has
multiple serotypes
and there are vaccines for ebv right now
through the similar type of mechanism
we have killed vaccines that have been
used
for canine coronavirus infectious
bronchitis virus
don't not us successfully but at least
they provide some
protection and there are vector vaccines
including adenovirus vaccines
for lactogenic immunity to transmissible
gastroenterology virus
and paculovirus for the spike smn
has been used for preventing energy
challenges there's also passive
immunization using neutralization of
antibodies as already has been used for
cells co2
and at the end up and in the body
dependent enhancement
with feline coronavirus vaccines
so for coffee dive team vaccines that
are in human trials and
already been out there in the market as
you know
mrna 1273 for moderna
is really the uh uh the entire spike
protein at least the entire
extracellular portion of the spike
protein
uh it has passed the phase three is
actually in the market it requires
two doses uh 28 days apart
and uh has been shown to be uh 94 to 95
percent efficacious in terms of
preventing the disease onset
the mrna bnt 162 pfizer
it has only the rbd the receptor
binding domain linked to a fibrin uh
neck
that facilitates standardization and so
basically it's a much
smaller target in terms of exchange and
that similarly has passed the phase
three trials
and that creates a single or two doses
that uh administrator a few weeks apart
we have a number of other vaccines that
are coming uh into play
we have the novio pharmaceutical link
there's a dna plasmid
we have the genset pharmaceutical
companies johnson johnson
as an adenovirus 5 vector vaccine
and oxford university which has the
zenica
in collaboration with the russian
company with sputnik uh which is the
vaccine adenovacine
they use a simian vector to express the
spike protein for vaccine purposes
and they report 50 to uh 90
efficacy also for this and those would
be are in the market already uh at least
the advent of our vectors are in the
market
um and then again this is something
about
uh why uh the dosage here you could see
that the moderna you have
up to 100 uh really micrograms
of pertoss that's a lot of rna which is
big codon optimized and includes
specific ribonucleotide nucleotides that
are being
placed as synthetic there to down
regulate the immune response
recognition by tlr3 tlr4 and tyler7
because rna in itself is very
inflammatory and in fact in certain
patients in germany and elsewhere
or accidentally were given five times
the dose they had severe problems
inflammatory response
anaphylactic shock and so on they have
different requirements being frozen or
not
and the the the physio vaccine
requires a minor 70 degrees because
really it's a much smaller protein and
the need to preserve the trimer
otherwise it falls apart although the
moderna has the entire spike that
naturally forms a primer and those both
the modernic has a nih-driven mutation
and i think i will talk about this that
keeps the spike protein
in an open conformation exposing the rpd
domain
to increase the ability to create
neutralizing antibodies
against the rbd domain i want to also
tell you that
we know in the past for uh sars called
one
that neutralizing antibodies and memory
b cell responses are short-lived
in cells recovery patients in human
patients and you can see here
that is under these patients that is the
cohort itself in black
patient a patient b that over time uh
in months you can see that the immune
response the b cell response ain't
nobody responds to be weighing out
and the question is although the studies
have been done two to three months right
now
it will be very interesting to see what
the results are six months
uh down the road whether you know b and
t
cell responses are really surviving
and uh they're not weighing out and
whether those people being vaccinated or
protected in the long
term
so this is what i wanted to tell you in
brief um if i want to sort of uh
quickly summarize before i recognize my
stuff here
is that uh two things uh susco
uh genotypes exist as a plethora of
genotypes in paths right now
over 400 genotypes in addition the
replication machine of these
coronaviruses
creates this uh quasi species
these variants in cell culture that
could be easily selected
based on external stimulus and external
selection
whether that would be an antiviral or a
immune selection so it's not surprising
then
that we could see variants evolving
these variants were not really
caused by mutational rates of the rdp
polymerase
although that also could play into this
but it could be
also pre-existing as part of the quasi
species that are naturally selected
in fact the thing eli would mention a
recent paper where
they took the virus oscar ii and they
put it in soul culture in the presence
of human antibody
and their selected variants very easily
that mimic some of the virus that we've
seen
so far so we're really at the beginning
understanding how these viruses evolve i
think bioinformatic
analysis is extremely important because
as we see these variants are coming
through
and maybe even detected them ahead as
part of the quasi species
we could potentially predict the outcome
of these variants which one would
persist
or create a different pathogenic profile
so i want to thank you for your
attendance and i want to acknowledge
people in my lab the
general general medical neurology cover
and paper on nelfina beer the difference
between spike
proteins for susco one and two were
worked
by dr fahana muserat and dr vladimir
cholchenko
also everybody else in the lab has
contributed to a lot of the work that
we're doing
so far including some of our vaccine
efforts that are ongoing
uh we have in the lab adenoviral vectors
and herpes vectors that express uh spike
protein
and we're actually involved in vaccine
experiments and of course
all our collaborators and acknowledge
the collaboration with lei brodsky
and the top biphemetics research center
at the university of haifa
which is really where um elia originated
at least the company got spun off
from the october center so thank you and
uh we can proceed then
elia with your presentation unless there
are some questions at this point
i know how you want to handle that
thank you guys yeah so i imagine that
some people might
have questions about your presentation
so we'll just
uh if you have any questions please put
them in the chat
we will address them maybe towards the
end of
my part of the presentation which is not
going to be very long
so again if you have any questions
and thank you guys for the presentation
please
put those in the chat
so um what i wanted to do is kind of
pick up on some of these topics and
expand a little bit
to talk about the bioinformatic aspect
of how we can piece together this data
where does the biology or the biological
understanding of this virus intersect
with the data that is available and that
is being generated daily
and how do we piece together the whole
puzzle to kind of think about
the impact of this rollout of the
vaccines
and the impact of how
diverse the virus will eventually become
as these additional treatments are
introduced and being used more widely
so as gus already mentioned many of the
vaccines
and early research on coronaviruses and
cyrus cliff 2
primarily has been focused on this key
role of the spike protein which plays an
important role
in zoonotic transmission and
in general in cell entry and so
when we look at the source code ii
genome you can see it's encoded right
here
um in this region and
what it does is it has this particular
property
uh that it actually is formed by these
two
subunits and those are cleaved
so that the s1 subunit can
attach to the membrane so what you can
see here
is the significance of some of those
terms that
gus was using throughout his part of the
lecture the receptor binding domain
and different parts of this spike
glycoprotein so
what has happened since then is that
there has been a
continuation of data collected from
these different studies and so here we
see
an excellent example of how structurally
people have started to understand
um the way that this protein works and
so what was done in this study
is that this spike glycoprotein
uh was captured connected to the virion
itself
and you can see that the virion actually
contains
um both of these conformations so you
can see
that in general has two forms the thin
structure
that resembles this needle-like
post-fusion structure
and then the wider one which is the
pre-fusion structure
and when they captured this intact
virion about
97 were pre-fusion and about three
percent were post-fusing
um and uh about 25
in total per virion the researchers also
examined
the thin and the wide trimer shapes and
found that they showed
um a very interesting correspondence so
we don't know everything about how this
works in real life
but this kind of data really allows us
to see
this structure intact and so what is
interesting about the structure is that
it's not static it's not always
kind of protruded outward but it
actually
can be found in many of these so it's
kind of shaking right so you can see
right here
that perhaps it's kind of dynamic
and so it also could be
in multiple ways either open closed
two open three closed one open right so
there's
a variety of shapes that you can expect
here so to really understand
how this connects with the genomic data
i think it's important to appreciate
that
data the majority of the data that we
have is actually genomic sequencing data
and so the genomic sequencing data
when it is pieced together with this
kind of an understanding of the
structure of these proteins
it really provides a lot of insight i
think into
how we can understand what's going on so
here you can see this
s1 subunit on top the s2sub unit on the
bottom
and here's a little video of what
happens if you
uh detach the top part so it's like a
cap that's sitting on top
and the reason i'm showing this is
because i think once we go into the
specific mutations it becomes very
interesting when you
think about how does this practically
work
so um when
originally the major question was
about the origin of this coronavirus and
i guess explained it in great detail
one of the major findings during that
time
was that the novel coronavirus was
very similar to one of the bad
coronaviruses that was captured not
long before the human version was
sequenced and so one of the questions
would be well what is different
between bats and humans
that so many different viruses that end
up
uh becoming endemic or pandemic
acquire these properties so how does
that
environment really play a role in what
happens and so
one of the things that you see here and
probably already recognize that the
majority of these mutations that
are differences essentially between
the rad g13 genome and the human cova-19
genome
are found in this receptor binding
domain region
but also if we look overall how these
relate to other bad coronaviruses
and other stars like coronaviruses
we can see that there are very specific
properties
that have been um acquired
through this transformation and so one
of the questions that was posed in this
paper
was um what is so unique about bats
that kind of uh you know puts them in
the center of all
of these pandemics and so um
on it i'll provide evidence that one
mechanism bats have evolved to limit
excessive inflammation during viral
infection
is to dampen transcriptional priming and
lower functional capacity of the bat
inflammasome
sensor and our family pyrin domain
containing three
um which is nlrp3
and it functions as a pathogen
recognizing receptor to activate
inflammatory mediators so this
inflammation has also been linked to
aging and age-related chronic diseases
and the study provides a mechanism for
and a provisional answer to whether bats
have evolved to tolerate or resist viral
infections so this work really suggests
that bats have adapted to tolerate viral
infection
without development of pathology through
inflammation
which explains essentially that the
virus
can replicate in a bat
without leaving the same host for long
periods of time
in fact i think in this paper it was
mentioned that it could be
several months that the virus replicates
continuously
inside the bat and this is very
different from the types of hosts that
do show inflammation
that have a kind of acute disease
um and um as a result of
both the pressure that the virus is
under
and the long time that it can uh kind of
exist in a single host makes it a unique
situation
where many novel mutations
recombination and properties are
acquired
so to understand some of these
properties right we started talking
about the different domains
and so one of these regions in
the receptor binding domain which you
can see here on top
is really the binding to the ace2
receptor and so it's easy to kind of
imagine how
because of this evolutionary pressure
for the virus to escape
this high pressure environment in the
bat find
new hosts eventually it is able to
primarily kind of adapt to these novel
h2 variants that are found in other
hosts
and so what we can see in this original
kind of those mutations that we were
looking at right is that those mutations
are very close to that binding so
again this is a trimer so you can see
here three times it's
the same thing is replicated and only
one of the receptor binding domains is
open and so you can see the ace2 the
portion of the h2 that is bound to this
receptor so
when we look at these mutations they're
found specifically in that
portion so now the question is right so
this was about the origin and this was
about the question well how did the
virus acquire the certain properties
how was it introduced into the human
population and so
now we have a lot more information about
what happened
after that so essentially if we look now
this was taken uh yesterday i think so
this is
uh from next strain a website that
displays
genomic information collected from
around the world and
analysis of that genomic information to
understand the relationship between the
different clades that are emerging
and what you can see here is first of
all how
uh the different clades are divided up
throughout the world
uh on the website itself you can see a
nice animation of how the viral
strains kind of originated from
different places and that's essentially
the goal of this analysis here on the
side is to demonstrate
how individual dots which are samples
are representative of different clades
and so you can see a phylogenetic tree
and if you see here on top there is a
total of
uh 12 plates right so right here if you
just count these up there's a total of
12 clades now what's interesting
is that this is showing essentially one
year so from
january 2020 to january 2021.
you can see how for a variety of reasons
really
there has been a gradual increase in the
number of
clearly defined clades so you can see
here we've got three up until about
february and then we have about five
here until may
and then about seven to eight kind of
emerge over this period of time because
one of them kind of disappears
almost and then today we're looking at
10 kind of major plates that are known
and then
here if you actually count all of these
you can see that some of them
are very minor right so some of them are
either emerging
just like we saw here so some of them
are emerging and growing in number
or some of them could be uh just kind of
coming appearing and disappearing
and so the reason i'm showing this is
because
we now have this tremendous collection
of genomic
information on one hand it allows us to
analyze the data and understand both the
origin
and the dynamics of this disease as it
spreads
on the other hand it is also limited due
to
a variety of biases for example we know
that most of these samples are collected
in
areas of outbreak right so if there's
not an outbreak
we don't have any information a lot of
the
sequencing also happens around the major
outbreaks
and so we do expect this
data to be informative but also some of
the questions could be limited but some
information is already emerging
that is going to be very interesting for
us to look at today
so for example one of the things that if
we
do the exact same thing on this
uh next train website you can zoom in
and you can look at how specific
proteins
acquire mutation so at what rate do they
acquire mutation
so an interesting thing would be to look
at the spike protein just like we were
looking in terms of the
zoonotic transmission and asked the
question well
how are these mutations distributed
throughout this
protein so you can see here this is the
spike protein so it's about
21 600 to about 25
400 that's the length of this
gene and here you can see the s1 subunit
and the s2 subunit
and so it's fairly clear that the s1
subunit has
many more mutations that we can observe
right here and so here we do have some
mutations but
essentially the s2 subunit has less
mutation
we can map this these mutations onto the
structure
of this uh protein data bank id uh pdb
uh 6vxx and kind of see visually
that the distribution is not random so
there is some pattern and that's really
what is
interesting about this is what is the
pattern
and what is shaping the pattern of
distribution of these mutations
to understand how can similar
events as we go through this uh pandemic
how can uh we kind of anticipate what's
going to happen and how can we detect
this early on
to be prepared to what's um going to
happen
so let's think about the selective
pressures
that this virus is undergoing
because right here you can see kind of a
nice
chart that was published not so long ago
where you can see the different
regions so the different genes on the
genome and the
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
and you can see that
orf 1a for example has the majority of
these mutations right so the y-axis is
the number of mutations and these are
the individual genes
so the first type of uh
kind of a selective pressure that we
know of is
rendezvous right and just in general
antivirals so how does
interlumdas severe work it's
a drug that is going to interfere with
the
rna polymerase or drp and
these antivirals essentially they are
intended to stop the ability of the
virus to replicate right so if the virus
actively replicates
uh rendezvous is supposed to reduce that
number
but at the same time it has kind of a
negative effect
why because the rdrp
is um can mutate right so in order to
evade this pressure
and you can see right here an example
from a publication where
such mutations were observed essentially
uh developing resistance to this
antiviral
so that's one type of pressures the
second one is
interferon so because there is
kind of a balance that ultimately is the
most beneficial to the virus
where the host doesn't die the host
continues to live
but also the pressure is not strong
enough to eliminate
the viral population so when that
balance is achieved right that is kind
of the optimal situation for the virus
but right now
there is the strong immune response we
know that the virus is
actively trying to control this immune
response
um and so there is some um optimization
still
in that process and so that's another uh
kind of
theoretically um evolutionary process or
a pressure
for the virus to achieve optimal balance
with the immune response
and then the long-term immunity right so
the antibodies
is another kind of a pressure so the
evasion
of this immune response of detection and
kind of a long-term sustained
recognition of the virus
is another major pressure so these three
pressures and we'll talk in the end of
how they
relate to um actual uh vaccine roll out
are kind of strong theoretically uh
pressures that we
should observe in the uh virus so let's
see
whether this has really been seen so
the first thing that we talked about is
remdevier
the way it happens is it actually
interacts here with the rdrp so
after the virus has entered the cell and
the rdrp has been produced it blocks it
and so that replication of subgenomic
transcription does not happen and so
what
happens is that it blocks a particular
binding pocket
and as a result that pocket becomes the
region of active mutations and so you
can see here
a paper that was recently published
where
emerging star scope 2 mutation hot spots
including novel rna-dependent rna
polymerase variant so rdrp
mutations and so here you have
the treated versus the untreated
samples and you can see that
specifically
in the treated ones there is
this kind of more narrow distribution of
these mutations which
indicates that you know on average
there's a rate of mutation that happens
throughout the whole
rdrp and then when we look at this
particular pressure it is more selective
and so this is
um again it has not necessarily been
um studied extensively in us enough for
us to understand
um what might be the rate or at what
levels
of uh remdissevere use throughout the
population these types of mutations will
occur
but it still allows us to anticipate
what might happen as a result of
antiviral treatment
now another kind of an aspect that we
talked about was this uh
ability of the virus to evade detection
um and one of the ways that it
evades detection is by these glycogen
molecules so glycosylation
essentially the spike protein is covered
with glycans
that are preventing accurate detection
of the full protein and to remain
flexible enough to bind to ace to
receptor you can see that
it actually is not covered throughout so
these are mutations
that happen as a result of this changing
dynamic structure of these glycans that
are covering the whole um
kind of body of this protein so um there
has also been some modeling done
to kind of show us what that really
looks like and so we are used to see
the spike protein like this in a naked
shape
and here you can see a model
computational model
um that shows what it looks like when
it's covered with these glycans and so
you can see
how essentially the top this receptor
binding domain
is open and so that's the critical part
for detection
but then a lot of the areas are covered
up with these glycans and that
helps the virus evade immune detection
and so
because of this we
know that um this uh you know specific
uh receptor binding domain is so
critical not
only because of the transmission the non
zononic transmission
but also um as the vaccines are being
developed to target that particular
domain
so the other studies that also gus has
alluded to
were done with the covalence and plasmid
so what is covalescent plasma
essentially it is a plasma collected
from patients that have
already recovered and so that has to do
with the process of disease progression
so
in the beginning there's this acute host
response
and then there's this kind of
response that becomes a long-term
response
and after that time after the person
recovers
that plasma could be collected and
essentially those antibodies are
could be used as a prophylactic or as a
treatment
and so here there is a study that was
done
again the study is not conclusive in the
sense that it was not
done in animal models or patients
but it has been observed so here you can
see
the x-axis is time in days
so from 0 to 100 days and
here you can see how these mutations
are starting to occur based on a number
of kind of variations that were done
in the cell culture experiment where
different dosages were administered for
a long time and so here you can see
different types of mutations and
deletions
that come out seemingly as a response of
administration of this plasma now one of
the things that
i think it's very nice to understand as
you're thinking about these mutations
is what is the actual structural
interaction between these
um antibodies and the spike protein
so um there's actually a uh uh
pdb structure that was published that
kind of shows us
exactly how that works so here you can
see
this um so again here it's showing
the antigen binding fragments so there's
the light chain
um and so the this is the outside
and so the antibody essentially
is blocking is keeping this protein
inactive by blocking these
receptor binding domains in a way that
they cannot access and bind
to the ace2 receptors so i think this is
why it's so important for us to link the
mutation data and the sequencing data
with the structural component because we
can really understand how these interact
so it's
really nice to have such models so this
particular antibody is
called ey6a it was retrieved from an
individual convalescing from covid19
and what they have done in this study is
they have shown that it neutralizes
sars cov2 and cross reacts with sars
code one so it's actually working with
both
both sarc 2 and sars1 it binds to the
receptor binding domain of the viral
spike glycoprotein
tightly and the complex
identifies the highly conserved epitope
away from the h2 receptor binding site
residues within this footprint are key
to stabilizing the pre-fusion spike so
again
how effective is this going to be this
um is actually a question right because
the
regulation of how the spike protein
opens up
and how different portions of it are
accessible and recognizable
is going to play a role in how this
evolves over time
so now another example i think is
to what gus alluded to here
about these quasi species or essentially
how instead of what we think of one
single genome in the host essentially
this is a whole population or a swarm
of competing virus genomes
that are essentially suppressed by this
more dominant more effective genome and
so
what has been shown fairly clearly is
that
most mutations are cleared out
and so the genome is fairly stable not
because there are no
other variants out there the population
is very diverse
but the other kind of variants that are
present in that
population are easily cleared out and so
one
key reason for that is because the
infection itself is fairly short so they
they don't stay in one host for a very
long time
but as that time grows
that's where you can start observing um
how this population really works and so
what they've done here
is actually this is a i'm going to talk
about a combination of two different
studies one study was
with immune so
people that have a poor immune response
and the other one is with people that
have
this prolonged chronic uh condition
and eventually are treated with
convalescent plasma
so um here this
shows the quasi species generation
so the wild type source cov2 which is
the most common form
serves as the reference rna sequence for
development
of an assay but we can see that this
essentially represents a whole kind of
you know each one of these clades here
represents a population
essentially and you can see here
individual patients so individual
patients
are going to be um are going to be shown
here
and you can see that some of them become
outliers and so what does it mean that
they are outliers essentially by
themselves
that means that they have some
established
strain from this population that
previously has not been the dominant
strain
and so when they wanted to characterize
what this these strains look like they
started looking at specific mutations
in the spike glycoprotein because
the only way to treat these people that
have this infection for a long time
is to administer them with convalescent
plasma from recovered patients
and so here you can see how these
specific mutations
including in the rdp rbd domain
in the fusion peptide in the heptad
repeat
right and the more importantly they
actually correspond
with the epitopes that are recognized by
the different
antibodies so this is one reason
why prolonged infection and seemingly
effective care
with multiple ways to intervene in the
disease actually could also
bring out through selective pressure
some of the
less dominant substrates that all of a
sudden
are not being captured in that treatment
right so the treatment
kind of suppresses the major dominant
strains and these
other clades these other quasi species
have more freedom to replicate and
become established and so
that in itself prolonged treatment
comorbidities
and uh the treatments with antivirals
and convalescent plasma
could lead to that effect now another
implication of that and this was
proposed this is a hypothetical
is that um you know theoretically
non-hispanic whites and african
americans might have
differences because of similar
properties right so here we see
comorbidities longer time different
types of immune responses
and because of that this kind of change
in the balance of the dominant
kind of quasi species could result in
uh lower detection and essentially
a higher mortality rate so this was a
model that somebody proposed
uh now already uh gus mentioned here
that
um there was uh there were additional
studies on
cell cultures and uh the object
objective of this
study here to show here is that
multiple mutations occur
at the same time and so you can see here
mutations
in this in the e and the n protein you
can see a mutation in the rdrp
and you can see multiple mutations in
orth1a
and these mutations actually happen in
different patterns
at different days and so one of the
studies wanted to see
what is the again structural component
of these mutated regions
and what they have discussed discovered
is that
one of them is directly related to
resistance to antibodies because they
examined
a published spike structure and kind of
annotated with the residues
and it showed that some of these
mutations happen
in a disordered glycosylated loop at the
very tip of the
uh um at the very tip right here
uh the ntd and therefore could alter
binding of
antibodies uh the other mutation right
here is close to the binding site of the
polyclonal antibodies derived from
co57 plasma 6 plasma
and also you can see that a lot of these
mutations essentially interact with
these antibodies
so what we can understand from here
is one that the longer
the disease the more
these mutations occur at multiple
regions at the same time and i think
another interesting thing that you can
see here
is that there are there are not only
mutations but there are
also deletions so another
thing that i think was overlooked in the
literature
there's a lot of conversation about
different mutations emerging
and being established in these clades
but
not a lot of people are looking at
multi-nucleotide deletions so not just
deletions
of signal nucleotides but deletions that
are longer so here you can see some
examples
so in the beginning what happened was in
this study the researchers were trying
to identify
deletions that are more than a single
nucleotide and you can see here some
shorter examples but you can also see
right here
this is deletion links and this is
number of events so if you just take
all of the publicly available data what
is the distribution
of deletion links and here you can also
see
that they have annotated specific
recurring deletions
that are more than a single nucleotide
and where they also happen right so i
think this is very interesting because
um there is this kind of a naturally
occurring
phenomenon where whole portions of
important genes could be deleted from
the viruses
and essentially that is a part of this
quasi-species dynamic where
defective genomes that might have a
profound effect on how these proteins
are actually produced
start interacting with the wild type
genomes
and so this is a part that i think is
going to be more and more
explored because essentially what it
shows us
is that we don't even know what other
members of the quasi species are out
there this is very poorly annotated and
very
poorly studied and at the rate of
infection
and as we see the number of established
clades grow
and as we see the number of mutations in
various regions grow
what it leads us to believe is that even
though
the current vaccine is going to be
and you know there are studies ongoing
right now to demonstrate whether it will
be
effective uh it's probably going to
go from very high rates of effectiveness
and that will go down but the good side
is that really these vaccines the mrna
vaccines at least and the vaccines that
are being produced kind of using
this you know novel technology are
also much easier to manipulate and so
continuous
surveillance of these viruses
especially using deep sequencing to
reveal the low frequency mutations
continuous monitoring of how this
kind of happens within patients that we
start to developing a sense of what
happens
in different cases in different clinical
scenarios
as well as ability to understand the
implication the functional implication
of these different mutations and to be
able to design
new versions of the vaccine right so i
think that
you know most of us at least i had this
anticipation that the vaccine will be a
final solution there will be
kind of a resolve of this pandemic and
you know it seems like
this is not necessarily true and there
there's a lot more research there's
going to be needed
to continue and explore how the dynamic
of this virus is going to continue and
change
especially after such widespread
vaccination
so before we conclude and go on to the
questions
i briefly wanted to mention that these
examples that we've introduced today
are essentially examples that we will
cover
in detail in the upcoming bioinformatics
for infectious disease graduate course
at lsu
which is also going to be available for
lbrn so
this is something that you can learn
more about on this link and i'm going to
just paste this link
in the chat box and this
program is essentially
designed to introduce biologists and
you know those that are interested in
such research
to be efficient with the data that's out
there that is being generated
with asking questions about the data and
being able to find
evidence in the data itself
to understand different methods of
analysis i think
what we can see from some of the
examples that we presented today
is that it's not just you know the same
method that solves
all the questions really this is a
combination of a variety of different
methods and that includes
sequence alignment that includes
evolutionary
studies that allow us to understand
relationships between
viruses and there are a lot of different
methods for that that include
a variety of different questions that
could be asked it's working with the
structural
proteins so all of the visuals of those
proteins
are very easy to produce but they are
very informative when you
identify those important mutations and
also
analysis of transcriptomic data so how
is the host responding
for example if we delete a certain
protein or we introduce a mutation how
can we study the results and understand
the structural kind of components and
what is the
functional result of those mutations
so this program is going to help you
understand pathogens and the diseases
that they cause we'll talk about source
code too but we'll also talk about other
types of
pathogens and we'll also talk about this
pathogen host interaction we'll talk
about
different types of analyses but also
where to find data
and how to start your bioinformatic
analysis from
data that's available and also what are
some of the applications of such
analysis how can this analysis can help
us
think about the function
how can it help us think about vaccine
design antivirals antibiotics
and how can it help us understand
epidemiological trans and drug
resistance
and also what's important is that we are
going to
actually take examples from the public
domain of data sets that have been
curated
with publication so a lot of the
examples that i presented today
the data is available in fact in terms
of
how much data is available there's over
3.5 million viral sequences and over 13
000 genomes out there so it's a huge
variety of data
this data is easy to find and easy to
use
and importantly i think since
ebola virus which was really the first
example
when you know immediately almost in real
time so much data has become available
with covet because so much focus on
covenant because
the availability of the sequencing
technologies
that rate of sequencing and availability
of data has grown
many fold and today there are just for
source code too there are over
180 000 sra runs which are fast q files
with a lot of information in them
um over 50 000 nucleotide uh
records and so um a lot of this
continues to
kind of accelerate as we speak um
importantly i think that these data sets
can provide
us with important insights and so
specifically we'll look at examples of
how
to correlate genomic diversity with
population for example geographic
location
we'll talk about immune responses and
how to find
biomarkers and we'll also talk about
association between pathogens and the
microbiome
and we'll also look at not just the
nucleotide and structure but we'll also
look at pathway analysis and
interpretation and things like that
we'll take a look at different types of
sequencing methods and how
those different sequencing methods
produce different type of data
and different type of data could be
analyzed using different types of
resources
and we'll also introduce you to some of
the typical
analyses without the need to use coding
so we'll do some coding but we'll also
primarily focus on the logic of analysis
so how to ask the right question
how to find the right method for
analysis and
also how can multiple methods of
analysis could be combined together
to really develop a sense of what's
going on in these complex relationships
like quasi species and hepatitis
or the emergence of more differential
mutations or less differential mutations
and how can we think about asking those
right questions
and answering them with the correct
methods
um so we have prepared a number of uh
kind of curated projects as i mentioned
that will explain some of these for both
asynchronous and
in-person sessions that we'll do on zoom
just like this
and we'll also be able to share those
for further study after that and so an
important part that
i wanted to mention is that all of these
program resources are going to be
available not just
for this graduate course but also for
the louisiana biomedical research
network so the louisiana biomedical
research network
will offer a lot of these resources
as a synchronous resources for faculty
to use and teach the students and also
to kind of explain how all of this works
we will have we will have a special
program
that's going to last for uh from now all
the way
until the summer where um you can have
access to
16 different hands-on asynchronous
courses uh the cloud research tools
uh some coding practical tools in r in
python and
online support from instructors and
i just wanted to make sure that we kind
of cover
all of these options and in maybe the
future
we'll also introduce in greater detail
specifically
what will the structure of the programs
be like
and how these programs can help faculty
graduate students
as well as undergraduate students so at
this point i'm
going to pause and just see if there are
any questions
um so again i will
i will read out some of the questions
that are available
right here in the chat
okay so um cerise is asking what percent
of the viral genome needs to be changed
mutated for a strain to be typically
considered
a quasi species
um so gus would you like to answer that
or or do you want me to
answer uh you know uh you can take a
shot at this and i could add to this if
you want like
okay so the um idea behind quasi species
is to identify so if you imagine a fast
q file and has a variety of reads and
we're talking about here whole genomes
is to identify groups so it's not
necessarily
how many mutations right so specifically
when we talk about quasi species
it's the detection of those and grouping
them by similarity
so what could be found is for example
mutations that are in close proximity in
one
region right and there's a lot of them
or you can find many of them distributed
throughout the genome
so it's not the number it's more how do
they form groups because
the main thing here is to differentiate
between
errors in sequencing and some technical
variants
as opposed to actual biological
representative of
a genome that is
potentially in this sample
uh did you want to answer that guess
yeah so basically
quasi species is really dependent
on the replication kinetics um so if you
look at cell culture
what we've done with bovine corona and
dr radavinchonjenko looked at that
if you look at the level of mutations of
the subgenuine
messages actually quite higher than what
you see in the genome as elia
mentioned because they're selected out
for stability purposes
of the genome level so there is a real
swarm for viruses but
most of them are really on lower they're
selected out so they're predominant
variants or predominant genotypes versus
minor genotypes but because of this
swarm
being available based on some selection
in cell culture in the absence of an
external selection
you're going to get a virus which would
be much easier
to replicate so it may not need specific
functions
so you are prone to get more deletions
and for non-essential genes
because the virus is optimizing its
genotype to really replicate efficiently
in cell culture
without having to worry about um
immunological
function and specifically for african
green monkey cells
which are interferon type one interferon
negative there's no even interferon uh
involvement so basically you're gonna
see certain variants
be selected because of the fact that
there's no interference around that
perhaps would influence the application
uh but i think the
the point to be to impress is that
the virus has quasi species swamped the
viruses
in addition to mutational rates on the
rna dependent polymerase
uh so it would be quite easy
for new variants to be created as elia
mentioned
based on even longer infections so the
longer the infection the higher the
chance
of a variant to be selected
and this is the issue because typically
in cysco 2
you may have 2 to 14 days
up to 3 weeks from primary infection to
show symptoms the virus could replicate
for up to 2-3 weeks and you may the
virus may be
around for months before it gets
eliminated by the immune system
in which case by the time uh the end
result
would be that the virus could be
transmitted in an altered form
to a subsequent person especially from
those shatters
that have virus for a long time
okay so there is hopefully okay yeah so
she said thank you
and i do want to mention about quizzes
pieces because i think this is a
fascinating uh
question in terms of the vaccines right
so as we think about this
um one of the methods that i had a
chance to work with was
called surseq and back then it was
applied to polio and dengue viruses but
the what it reveals is kind of like a
fitness
landscape of how
the virus kind of selects
the dominant genome that we essentially
sequence right so when we sequence
the majority of the sequencing
information is going to come from that
dominant
kind of genome but if we had a lower
detection limit so the rate of errors
would be lower then we could pick up
these lower
frequency mutations and if we do we
could study the landscape to understand
which ones are more likely to be
beneficial
sort of for the viral replication for
the
overcome of these immune pressures etc
so i think one of the
opportunities here with these novel
sequencing technologies the longer reads
the lower error rates
the novel library preparation techniques
is really an opportunity to survey
the population in much greater detail
and perform these experiments to
understand
what's the logic behind the emergence of
some of these
low frequency mutations that already
exist in the population right they're
not necessarily new mutations they just
become more detectable as we
see the whole population kind of change
because of these pressures
and as eli mentioned the issue there's
vaccines especially the physio vaccine
which is only the rbd domain
uh obviously you do have potent
neutralizing antibodies created as well
as cd4
cda t cells uh because our epitopes
there uh
but it's very possible that the efficacy
of this vaccine
will wane with time uh it's not going to
be as bad as flu vaccines because of
you know genetic diversity and
reassortment but you will be variants
created then the
the end point would be that those
vaccines could be a few cases of 50
or less which require an adjustment
on probably on a yearly basis or even
earlier uh having a vaccine that may
then target a new genotype
all right great so i know that we went a
little bit over time already so we're
not going to make it too long it's
already 4 20
4 30 almost on friday so um thank you
everyone for joining today
we will follow up we have most of your
registration information for this
webinar so we will follow up with some
more information about
these upcoming programs and we will
probably have another webinar
about the specific program structure
uh right for a louisiana biomedical
research network
and others and i do want to mention i
see that some people are asking here in
the chat privately
that we have some other similar programs
that essentially are ongoing at
university of ghana
um and uh with some other universities
so
we'll share that information with you um
by email and then for the lbra network
you'll find this information on the lbrn
website although they may not be
enrolled to your actual credit course
right